.
GREAT SHOW TONIGHT I ENJOYED
WATCHING IT.
SEE YOU LATER.
I'M LAURA INGRAHAM, THIS IS
INGRAHAM ANGLE FROM WASHINGTON
TONIGHT WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS
FROM JOURNALIST CHRIS RUFO WE'RE
GOING TO BRING YOU IN MOMENTS.
AND ONCE AGAIN THE LEFT IS
SEEKING TO USE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO TARGET THOSE WHO
SPEAK OUT.
THIS TIME AGAINST THOSE WHO
OPPOSE RADICAL GENDER SURGERIES.
THOSE DETAILS ARE JUST MOMENTS
AWAY.
BUT FIRST, UNNATURAL DISASTERS.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
NOW, JUST WHEN YOU THINK THE
REGIME MEDIA COULDN'T DO MORE TO
SHATTER ITS OWN CREDIBILITY,
THAT'S PRECISELY WHAT THEY DO.
>> THE CLEANUP EFFORTS WILL
CONTINUE, AND SO WILL THOSE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE RESPONSE.
WAS IT ADEQUATE ENOUGH?
>> WE HEARD WHAT GOVERNOR
DeSANTIS SAID BUT WE SHOULD NOTE
THAT, AS YOU EMPATHIZE MAUDE I
CAN'T, THAT RESIDENTS THERE ARE
QUESTIONING WHY THEY WEREN'T
TOLD TO EVACUATE SOONER.
>> NOW GOVERNOR DeSANTIS,
MICHAEL, HAS BEEN QUITE HANDS ON
WHEN IT COMES TO MOVING MIGRANTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO PROVE A
POLITICAL POINT.
SHOULD HE BE SHOWING THE SAME
DEDICATION TOWARDS SAVING LIVES
AHEAD OF A HURRICANE.
>> WHAT IS YOUR SENSE OF, YOU
KNOW, WHEN THE EVACUATION ORDERS
WENT OUT?
DID THAT GO OUT EARLY ENOUGH?
>> OBVIOUSLY ABOUT ONE TIME IN
TEN WHEN THEY WARN YOU IT
HAPPENS.
WELL, THIS IS THAT ONE TIME AND
PEOPLE DID NOT REALLY EVACUATE
AS THEY SHOULD HAVE.
>> Laura: NOW, YOU COULD SENSE
THERE, RIGHT, THAT ACOSTA WAS
DEBT SET ON SQUEEZING OUT ANY
CRITICISM, NO MATTER HOW TEPID
OF DeSANTIS FROM THAT GUEST.
WELL, NONE OF IT LANDED.
THE FACT IS, FLORIDA WAS HIT BY
A NATURAL DISASTER.
BUT FLORIDA WILL RECOVER BECAUSE
ITS PEOPLE HAVE A COMPETENT
GOVERNOR, AND THUS THEY'RE
HOPEFUL ABOUT THE FUTURE.
NO WONDER CNN THE LIKES OF
MAGGIE HABERMAN AT THE NEW YORK
TIMES ARE WORKING OVERTIME TO
CAST DESERTIONS AND SO DISTRUST.
HURRICANE IAN WAS DEADLY AND
HORRID BUT HURRICANE IAN AS IN
CUOMO AND HURRICANE KATHY AS IN
HOCHUL AND THAT WIDE STORM SURGE
FROM HURRICANE GRETCHEN IN
MICHIGAN AND CHICAGO'S CAT FIVE
HURRICANE LURIE AND THE EVER
EXPANDING HURRICANE JB AS IN
PRESS KERR.
THE CATASTROPHIC RUIN THEY'VE
HALL LEFT IN THEIR WAKES WILL
REQUIRE YEARS, NOT MONTHS, OF
CLEANUP.
THE RESULTS OF THEIR TERRIBLE
POLICIES, PRO CRIMINAL AND ANTI
BUSINESS, THEY CAN'T BE REMOVED
WITH A CRANE.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE MULTIPLE
DEFEATS FOR THEM AND THEIR PARTY
AT THE BALLOT BOX.
BUT REAL REPORTERS WOULD BE
POUNDING THESE PATHETIC
GOVERNORS ON THEIR RECORDS AND
PRESSING THEM RELENTLESSLY ON
WHY, FOR INSTANCE, ILLINOIS,
CALIFORNIA AND NEW YORK ARE
LOSING SO MUCH OF THEIR
POPULATION TO STATES LIKE
FLORIDA, AND TENNESSEE, AND
TEXAS.
HOW ARE THOSE WINNING RECORDS IF
YOU'RE LOSING YOUR OWN PEOPLE?
OF COURSE, MOST OF THE REPORTERS
WHO PLAY DEFENSE FOR THESE
FAILED POLITICIANS LIVE
THEMSELVES IN WELL-TO-DO URBAN
NEIGHBORHOODS.
THEY'RE COCOONED IN BY THEIR OWN
BUBBLES OF COMFORT SO THEY INS
LATE THEMSELVES FROM THE FALLOUT
OF THEIR ON HERO'S POLICIES THAT
OBVIOUSLY REGULAR WORKING FOLKS
CAN'T ESCAPE.
YET THEY'RE ROOTING NOW AGAINST
FLORIDA'S GOVERNOR IN A TIME OF
CRISIS.
IT'S JUST SO LAME AND IT'S SO
SLEAZY.
BUT A LOT OF THESE FOLKS ARE
USED TO LYING WITH IMPUNITY.
FOR WEEKS THEY'VE BEEN PUSHING
THE FALSE CLAIM THAT BIDEN IS
STAGING SOME 11TH HOUR COMEBACK
JUST IN TIME FOR THE MIDTERMS.
BUT SINCE AUGUST THE ANGLE HAS
TOLD YOU THAT THIS WAS UNTRUE.
BUT THEY'RE STILL TRYING TO PUT
LIPSTICK ON A DONKEY HERE.
THE NEW YORK TIMES NATE COMBS
DID HIS BEST MAKEUP JOB SAYING
THE IDEA DEMOCRATS CAN HOLD THE
HOUSE IS NOT AS RIDICULOUS
INPLAUSIBLE AND FARFETCHED AS IT
DID BEFORE THE DOBBS OVERTURNED
ROW VERSUS WADE.
IT'S A REAL POSSIBILITY NOT IN
THE SENSE THAT ANYTHING CAN
HAPPEN.
OTHER PRETEND REPORTERS AT
POLITICO ARE TRYING A NEW LINE
FLYING THE IDEA THAT RURAL
VOTERS ARE DEMORALIZED AND WON'T
SHOW UP TO VOTE.
NOW, THEY HANG THIS WISHFUL
THINKING IN POLITICO ON THE
SLIGHTLY RURAL LOWER TURNOUT IN
A FEW RECENT SPECIAL ELECTIONS.
THEN THEY ATTRIBUTE THIS TO THE
DOBBS DECISION.
AND THEN THEY EXTRAPOLATE TO
INDICATE THAT THIS COULD PRESS
VOTING PATTERNS IN NOVEMBER.
THIS IS LUDICROUS.
EVEN NEO FIGHTS KNOW THAT
MIDTERM ELECTIONS ARE
HISTORICALLY REFERENDA ON THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THE WHITE
HOUSE'S PERFORMANCE.
SO IT MIGHT BE A GOOD TIME TO
ASK HOW IS THE WHITE HOUSE DOING
RIGHT NOW?
WELL BIDEN APPROVAL'S AT 38%,
AND THE GOP IS WINNING NUMEROUS
GENERIC BALLOTS IN A ROW NOW.
MONMOUTH POLLING HAS THE
PRESIDENT GETTING TROUNCED ON
ISSUES THAT MATTER MOST TO THE
VOTERS.
ONLY 3 IN 10 AMERICANS APPROVE
OF THE JOB BIDEN HAS DONE ON THE
NATION'S TOP CONCERN, INFLATION,
30%.
AS WELL AS THE OTHER CONCERNS
THAT REPUBLICANS ARE FOCUSED ON,
IE CRIME, A 32% APPROVAL ON
IMMIGRATION, A PATHETIC 31%
APPROVAL.
SO THESE ARE AMONG THE UNNATURAL
DISASTERS THAT BIDEN AND THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE DROPPED ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE CAUTION
IMMEASURABLE TRAGEDY AND DAMAGE
ALONG THE WAY.
AND YOU BET THE VOTERS ARE
NOTICING.
SO GIVEN THE CYCLONE OF BAD
NEWS, THE REGIME MEDIA IS TRYING
DESPERATELY TO FIND A RAINBOW.
WHICH MEANS BLAME SHIFTING AWAY
FROM BIDEN AND TOWARD THE FED.
>> I REALLY DON'T KNOW WHAT, YOU
KNOW, I DON'T, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
POWELL IS DOING WITH RAISING
INTEREST RATES.
>> PEOPLE THINK JAY POWELL IS
ASLEEP AT THE WHEEL.
>> JAY POWELL IS DRIVING THE
ECONOMY INTO A BRICK WALL AND
IT'S BECOME A LIABILITY AT THIS
POINT.
>> Laura: WHAT EXACTLY WOULD ANY
OF THEM HAVE POWELL DO?
I'M NOT A BIG FAN OF POWELL'S
BUT BIDEN IS THE ONE WHO WAS
DOWNPLAYING THE RED LIGHTS
FLASHING 18 MONTHS AGO ON
INFLATION AND DEPLETELY
DISMISSING LARRY SUMMERS PUMPING
OWL BILLIONS IN MORE COVID
RECOVERY CASH WHICH SUPER
CHARGED INFLATION.
IT WAS ALL SO PREDICTABLE.
AND NOW, WELL, INFLATION IS
DEVOWING UP THE 5% WAGE
INCREASES THAT WORKERS HAVE, ON
AVERAGE, SEEN.
AS FOOD PRICES FOR THE YEAR THAT
ENDED IN AUGUST INCREASED BY A
STAGGERING 13.5%.
THAT IS -- GAS PRICES ARE
CLIMBING AGAIN WE KNOW THAT,
OPEC IS SHRINKING ITS OUTPUT BY
A MILLION BARRELS A DAY.
AND BECAUSE BIDEN HAS KNEE
CAPPED OUR OWN OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY, WE'RE AT OPEC'S MERCY.
HOW WONDERFUL.
HOW SICK IS THIS?
SOON WE'RE ALL GOING TO BE AT
SIX BUCKS A GALLON FOR GAS THAT
THEY'RE ALREADY PAYING NOW IN
CALIFORNIA.
YAY.
OTHER THAN THAT, HOW WAS THE
PLAY, MRS. LINCOLN.
NOW, ONCE IN A WHILE, THOUGH,
TRUTH DOES SLIP IN.
SOME MEDIA OUTLETS ARE NOW
FINALLY REPORTING ON WHAT WE
TOLD YOU GOING BACK TO, WHAT WAS
IT?
MAY 2020.
WHEN IT WAS CLEAR DEMOCRATS WERE
DETERMINED TO KEEP THEIR CITIES
AND STATES IN COVID LOCKDOWNS.
>> POWER HUNGRY GOVERNORS ARE
ENDANGERING THEIR STATES FUTURES
AND WILL EVENTUALLY SEE THEIR
STATES LEFT BEHIND.
NOW, IT TOOK THE ECONOMIST
MAGAZINE 27 MONTHS TO CATCH UP
WRITING, BY JUNE 2022, ON
AVERAGE TRUMP COUNTIES HAD NOT
ONLY BOUNCED BACK BUT HAD
SURPASSED THEIR PRE PANDEMIC
EMPLOYMENT AND LABOR FORCE
PARTICIPATION RATES.
BIDEN COUNTIES ARE NOT YET CLOSE
TO A FULL RECOVERY.
THE CRUEL, COSTLY, UNNATURAL
DISASTERS WE ARE NOW FORCED TO
ENDURE COURTESY OF THE
DEMOCRATS.
THEY'RE REALLY TOO NUMEROUS TO
COUNT TONIGHT.
THE CLEANUP IS GOING TO TAKE
WISDOM, COURAGE, AND LOTS OF
HARD WORK.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A NEW SENATE,
A NEW HOUSE, AND NEW LEADERSHIP
AT ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT.
IT'S TIME TO CHOOSE PRACTICING
MA ACTIVITYISM COUNTRY, FREEDOM
OVER FEAR AND SOUND SOLUTIONS
OVER SILLY SOCIALISM.
WE'RE ALWAYS GOING TO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH NATURAL DISASTERS.
BUT NO LONGER SHOULD WE TOLERATE
PO